she's here congratulations this is you
know quite it's quite a bold move it's
it's quite a statement that you that you
clearly wanted to make to say I'm going
to enter this beauty pageant
and now I'm going to talk about the fact
that actually I've got a colostomy bag
which is one of those issues that
affects a lot of people but they just
don't talk about exactly and that's
that's exactly why I really want to
raise as much awareness as I can for
especially young people with stomas
because when I came out of hospital I
really had nobody to relate to there
wasn't enough in the media and there
wasn't enough coverage for people in my
position so I felt very isolated and so
this is why I'm here to just try and be
said a positive message about having an
ileostomy I mean many people would have
sort of hidden away but you've chosen
not to enter this beauty competition and
perhaps there are those that might have
been put off by the fact that there
possibly could be swimwear round but
there wasn't in this particular no there
was an a lot of the systems now they
don't do a swimwear round and it's dead
it's been replaced with an eco round
where we encouraged design our own
outfit out of eco eco wear and things so
I decided to make a mermaid themed
outfit for the raising awareness of
ocean protection which is something I'm
quite quite dear to me so obviously
you've got your your rain which is now
underway and clearly you've got a vote
you've got a very sort of positive
message to get out there do we know how
many young people are affected by having
to have an ileostomy I think there are
more than you realize I like I said when
I came out of hospital I felt very very
isolated but when I really looked into
the colostomy Society and found a lot of
social media a lot of groups on social
media though there was actually
surprisingly a lot of people that were
the same age as me
who had some sort of ostomy was that
something that you sort of had to
research and seek out yourself yes it
was yeah they're the medical support was
brilliant in the hospital you know we
were given all of the advice that we we
needed at that point but when obviously
I left hospital there was really no you
know I felt like I was the the only
young person with a stoma and if it
wasn't for I think the stoma nurses who
said you know there are support networks
out there you just need to find them
really so I just wants you get in touch
with one group you get in touch with
another and before you know it there's a
whole world of people out there that
have got hasta music see what is what is
nice with this is that for anyone
watching I mean right now who feels
isolated you're opening up a whole new
world you're saying there is there is
support out there there are other people
like you out there and life can actually
be alright it can to be honest with you
life is brilliant now much better than
when I had the the disease I had which
was ulcerative colitis it was
debilitating there wasn't you know it
completely completely stopped my life
and when I had the surgery done it just
restored that for me and I could go on
and just be you know have quite a normal
life actually it's not sort of fected be
too much other than some things have had
to change like what I've had to eat what
I can wear but yeah ultimately it's a
great way of life and it's not something
you shouldn't really have to hide she
just just be yourself yeah a great
message Rachel really good to see you
thank you very much it's nice to have a
supportive family as well and that's
your lovely daughter at the crown oh she
has her own crowd pink arrows but no
she's not she's not really what what's
your another beauty queen Maya come in
the middle here Maya because get you
close to my mic are you proud of mom she
a great mom and beautiful mom
good girl
thank you very much both of you lovely
to see you thank thank you